You can never
really put your finger
on exactly what caribou are going to do.
They move from one place to another
and just
when I think I start to understand them,
they do something completely different.
So I just woke up and came outside
to go to the bathroom with Java,
and there's like
a couple of dozen caribou,
like sleeping on the lake right now.
Gotta be quiet.
Gotta be super quiet.
The snow is really crunchy right now.
Generally, this time of year,
the caribou are all far gone.
So I've been like subsisting off
of small game, squirrels, rabbits.
There they are.
It's like a fire [inaudible]
it's like
can’t really prepare for this kind of
thing they just go down so fast.
Like I haven't had breakfast.
I haven't had coffee.
I haven't got anything
And they're not losing their sleep.
It's like the most incredible thing
I've seen.
It's gotta be one of
the hardest stalks
you can ever put on a caribou.
I hear about six, 700 yards away from them
Basically what happened was
one of them felt uneasy and it jumped up.
Herd instinct, the rest of them jump up.
Some of them are still laying down.
They're starting to kind of go
back down a little bit.
So I'm just going to let them be at ease.
They don't have the best eyesight,
so they're going to think that
I'm a caribou..
As long
as I'm not posing any sort of threat.
So why approach this?
Let them see me.
So none of them get rattled
and jump up like they just did.
So if they're all just looking at me
and I'm kind of just walking at them
slowly not posing a threat,
they're going to let me walk toward them.
Let's go.
Holding the gun above my head.
Just kind of show it's like antlers.
It's the little subtle
things like that encourage
the caribou to believe
that I'm just another caribou
This is the craziest stalk man.
I've gone, like, 100 yards.
It's freaking nerve-wracking man.
Try to close that gap a little bit more.